- SO YOU GOT TO KEEP
THE TOPPINGS FULL.
- OKAY, GOT IT.
I'M ON TOP OF THAT.
- YOU GONNA FIT IN
JUST FINE HERE.
HEY, SOMEDAY...
THAT MIGHT BE YOUR PICTURE
ON THE WALL.
- OH, EMPLOYEE OF THE YEAR.
WHEN DOES SHE WORK?
- WHAT?
- I WAS JUST WONDERING
WHEN SHE WORKS.
- GIRL, IT'S ME.
- OH...
CONGRATS.
- NOW, HERE'S THE BEST PART
ABOUT WORKING AT A YOGURT SHOP,
IS YOU GET
ALL THE FREE FROYO YOU WANT.
MM-HMM.
AND YOU CAN'T BELIEVE
HOW DELICIOUS IT IS
AND ALSO FAT FREE.
THANK GOD,
BECAUSE MY BOYFRIEND--
HE JUST GOT BACK
FROM HIS TOUR IN AFGHANISTAN,
AND HE'S COMING HERE
TO PICK ME UP.
HE SHOULD BE HERE IN A MINUTE.
I HAVEN'T SEEN HIM IN A YEAR.
- A WHOLE YEAR, YOU SAY.
- MM-HMM. HAVE SOME.
- I'M GOOD.
- NOW, IF YOU NEED A EXTRA SHIRT
OR ANYTHING,
THEY GONNA BE IN THERE,
BECAUSE THESE SEEM TO SHRINK.
- UH-HUH.
- OKAY, YOU KNOW WHAT, GIRL?
I CAN'T GET ENOUGH
OF THIS STUFF.
I MEAN, YOU SHOULD HAVE SOME.
IT'S FREE.
- NO, I'M OKAY.
I'M--I'LL HAVE SOME LATER.
- COME ON, GIRL, IT'S FAT FREE.
- HI. I JUST GOT BACK
FROM AFGHANISTAN.
I'M HERE LOOKING
FOR MY GIRLFRIEND, LATIA.
- AAH!
BABY!
BABY, WHAT--WHAT?
IT'S ME.
- NO, IT'S NOT.
- WHAT? IT'S ME.
- APPARENTLY SHE DOESN'T WORK
HERE ANYMORE.
THANKS.
- WHAT?
OH, MY GOD!
HE'S LEAVING ME!
DESMONA, IS HE LEAVING ME?
DESMONA, WHY WOULD HE LEAVE ME?
WHAT--WHAT POSSIBLE REASON COULD
THERE BE FOR HIM LEAVING ME?
FOR HIM LEAVING ME?
- MAYBE HE--
MAYBE HE GOT THAT PSD. PSD.
- WHAT? OH, YOU MEAN THE PTSDs?
- THE PTSDs.
- YOU MEAN THE POST-TRAUMATIC
STRESS DISORDER.
[crying]
IT'S GOT TO BE THAT.
OH, MY GOD!
MY BABY GOT THE PTSD!
THAT COULD BE THE ONLY REASON!
OH, MY BABY!
MY POOR, POOR BABY
GOT THE PTSDs!
OH, MY BABY!
[wailing]